The Joe Rogan experience.
That's like a,
the Indian footage they found um,
footprints of what they think is
big foot in India and people saying,
Hey asshole, this is an animal hopping.
Yeah, this thing's only got one leg.
If there's a big foot, it's
a one legged, big foot.
Like some doctor Seuss creature.
Like they're like look stupid.
That's not two feet. That's not bipedal.
What do you guys do? Look at that.
That's one leg. Look at that.
Yeah. Boing. Boing. Boing.
That's an animal jumping you assholes.
The thick part is where their
butland's the front part is their paws.
They just keep going. See you see
one of them. It's even broken up.
Like look at that one picture where like
one of those footprints is actually two
separate marks in the, in the snow.
I'm not even a wildlife biologist.
The one right there. I'm not
even a wildlife biologist.
Rabbit Bro. It's a rabbit.
Those are kind of big via rabbit though.
Like a whole body rabbit,
rabbit, they some big ass rabbits. How
big the router Himalayas duty you seeing?
I don't know. That's what I want to
ask you the question to Himalayas,
like what would it be? What, what
is your animal? It could be, well,
one of the things,
this is very interesting about animals
is that when they go further north,
contrary to logic, like what you
would think they actually get larger,
you would think, well, it's colder
up there. They probably get smaller,
little thicker, but no, they preserve
their body temperature by being larger.
That's why Moose are so big.
They're the furthest north, uh,
of all the cows makes she makes sense.
Totally makes sense.
If you get a deer from Mexico,
they're tiny. They're like
a hundred pounds, right?
There's a deal. Do your call, the coups
deer and a really big one is a hundred.
It's cows or coups depending on
who you asked. C O u s but it's a,
a variation of the white tail
deer that's really small.
It only weighs like 100 pounds and it's
in Mexico full ground one. It's like a,
like a dog size.
Right.
And then there's other ones that are in
Saskatchewan that same species that are
300 pounds.
How do you know so much about deers?
Because I killed them and ate them.
Oh, you're a, I forgot you're out.
That explains the giant bow outside.
Yeah. Ah, that's how I get my meat.
Nopes please.
You know what a supermarket like everyone
else had to go to supermarket occasion,
but most, most of the meat that I eat,
I try to eat from animals that I kill.
Where do you hunt and La. Not La is
tricky. The tents get in the way.
You're lying to say the lineup.
Yeah.
But you can get a lot of coyote hunting
in La if you want this fucking coyotes
everywhere out here. Man. We
should eat a coyote from La. Uh,
I don't think I'd eat a coyote
period. Right? Yeah, less
than that. It was a goof.
Uh, or I was really hungry.
You can eat them though. I
mean you can, it's just meat.
Yeah, it's, you'd have to
cook it really, really well.
But when you cut away all the fur and
mange and all the shit on the outside
watch left, just getting a tissue.
Where do you, uh, what do you hunt?
Typically the mountains.
Usually every year I go to
Utah in the mountains of Utah.
Go El Co. What do you got Jim? Further
explanation on this. Oh, it's a bear.
Okay. They call Yeti something
different about him. Elaine Brown bear,
or a Tibetan blueberry. Oh,
what they, with all due respect,
what we call Yeti is with all probability,
the either the,
Oh, no, no, no. Okay. Then
it's not like they called the
Himalayan Barry Yeti. Right.
It's like they're saying
that it was probably a bear
that was making those marks.
That makes sense. If those are big marks
at the bears, hopping through the snow,
if it sticks now, that's a,
that makes sense. That guy,
who knows he's a nice guy with
all due respect to everyone. Yeah.
Single footprints or when the bear walks
on four feet. Yeah. That makes sense.
All right.
Yeah.